oh man my name and welcome to Jimmy
there's the guy who knocks on the door
he wants my sweetheart apparently is not
a boss but we need to [ __ ] it yeah oh
not for lunch well hey stop no fireballs
inside did your mama teach you that no
fire bonds and yeah dumb ass huh all
right so I read your breasts comments
and I will try to use the P dat a bit
more and investigate more but I will
still play how I wanted I'm sorry ah
[ __ ] you me I'm so scared I'm so scared
I'm so screwed I'm so screwed man
okay we need some sort of tactic go and
if we're gonna make this one
I think your girls are right I
definitely need to collect more ammo and
[ __ ]
alright [ __ ] you can't do [ __ ] brah Wow
the hell man alright Oh two shotguns
holy [ __ ] alright calm down calm down
calm down
yeah you he was calm
it wasn't calm all right how are you
doing that
alright good coming after me bro well I
knew I couldn't rocksbox
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] me
alright come on bruh [ __ ] joke
finally all right quick save on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] Fox man oh don't waste
Emma I'm sorry
never again sneaking up on me
hey goddamn fireballs man where do you
go
stupid [ __ ] I'm right here alright
well add that must be good things all
right we got a PDA - read it it's
Jonathan Mose alright let's see what has
to say no audio logs but he has emails
free stuff alright our free promotional
storage that's awesome
there isn't see your storage cabinet
where you would like to put it
alright maybe there's like a password or
some [ __ ] in it nope thank you for the
Quaker pie
can't wait all right good for you man
good for you
this is the camera Oh free stuff all
right it's gotta be in this [ __ ] come on
uh-huh visit us online well what the
[ __ ] how do I visit you or like Martian
body DICOM maybe I should do that just
to see I wanted to pray stop where would
you it doesn't say anything else
I want the free stuff come on ah come up
don't wait that well I'm sorry alright
maybe later
oh thank you that is really nice
okay oh we're up here now
Bravo Team of course there's some sort
of unidentified growth taking over parts
of the baby huh
[ __ ] me you know what it is but it can't
be good well I don't think it's good
either
come on why was that I don't like this
more what [ __ ] fire both man pissing
me off
last night time our
[ __ ] I hate you my undying hate man all
right whoa whoa whoa
damn it man let's check down here how
sweet is this all right a lot of health
weight this is where he came from
so we're going here
ah [ __ ] whoa ha ha that's all he can't
see me hey stop stop not healthy not
healthy all right what do we got shelves
and med kits hide in that tire call well
what ah
no demon
die oh yeah [ __ ] when I reload BAM
what the [ __ ] demon sacrifices and [ __ ]
Jeremy is probably up to this that what
the hell Jeremy
once I get a hold of where I am here we
go
what did i do what did i do I didn't do
anything I swear to God
I'd do anything let's check the PDA that
I got all right
director new webpage called missing
person religious artifact [ __ ] me it's
very important
it sounds very important we came from
here and we what the [ __ ] man
I got a security armor that sounds
pretty badass in my opinion why don't do
this guy I love ya
well I'm back here you kidding me this
is that what am I supposed to go check
fine all right
well okay damn oh no no no no all right
one two that's how I roll that's how I
get all the ladies all right any
questions any questions
ah - a sauna where's my ice fleshly
there we go
well I need to do that South Station
treat me nice
I got [ __ ] League Dharma and [ __ ]
it's gotta be PDA for this one video
disc holy [ __ ] let's check that out
where is it
how do I open the video disc maybe I put
it somewhere
I want the Alpha labs oh all right
good we are in the Alpha lab nice it's
like a nice place I bet that made a lot
of nice people here don't sneak up on me
alright let's check the PDA I guess
admin Paul Simon security specialist an
IT support network security has been
breached several times over the last few
days now it looks like it may have been
going on longer than that but whoever
did this really knew what they were
doing
goddamn hacker over the tracks really
well I just happened to notice some log
anomalies or would still be going on
okay intrusion came on an encrypted
carrier signal from the Delta complex of
course piggyback the virus and one of
the supercomputer requests and appealed
itself from the data stream once it was
inside our firewall this makes too much
them inside there has to be responsible
unfortunately due to security in that
complex I can only tell it came from
within Delta data to identify which
machine or even which laughing all right
you know like this car never was ni
system had access to all personal data
including medical reports no my dad
laughing and networked closely in the
next few days looking for anything
unusual in the vlog all right don't
doubt that [ __ ] you're on oh I'm here
what alright so we're going to Delta
labs then
yay Apple Adventist I don't even know
I'm doing good yeah it's be a pretty
good thought fine
I'm not bang that much what today thank
you for attempts I'm reading really up
so much so much save lives every day
every day during the book can you save a
life which way I've received a report
that you have to reach Bravo TV actor we
vow to come up to naming holy Scheffel
communication quickly is imperative all
right whatever
what open
yeah but the ladies where's my ladies I
order ladies you can order that on eBay
I think we're you sneaky [ __ ] even
get fatties now you got patted on your
side
oh no all right wanna buy one one one
bun don't hit me don't slap me when I
can't wish I could just [ __ ] to see
you all right one at a time ladies
is he bad wait is it going on anyone
else when a tango don't stop me don't
stop it you like that you like that oh
goody I like on goodies I have a lot of
health man getting heated this [ __ ] all
right
don't know I got a lot of em of that but
that's okay why can't they go there
why not why why would I go back oh never
again
wait can't wait cannot be Pat's I don't
like it
ah dick shots that very time anyway
god damn I hate them [ __ ] they [ __ ] my
life
where's the health station all right
again let's go back [ __ ] all the ladies
there we go
next one next one
well I'm looking at the scenery
whoa
what the [ __ ] is going on here
all right fine you don't interrupt my
diamond plants
come on everyone is just one to pick me
I don't know why but why are you hiding
there no no better no better what is
going on right now
[ __ ] off what the hell is going on right
now what the [ __ ] why do you [ __ ]
toilet this after me
[Music]
please stop stop duck Duck Duck everyone
to stop stop stop take a break
timeout time I tell me how much Kelly so
much melancholy it's not no Iseman oh
man that's how I roll what happened
there [ __ ] [ __ ] dude jumped in my
face god damn it what is it [ __ ] you
made me fall in [ __ ] I'm gonna kill you
what I'm gonna count you twice great I'm
sniffing F up
damas nepo Oh recoil nipple
oh oh man yes I want that PDA Kyle
burger I want that [ __ ] come on I
clicking PDA what o'clock okay Kyle
burger you're gonna make me rich beef
burger research supervisor
Shh the elemental phase Deconstructor is
fully operational in the research tray
that we have gathered so far very
impressive
uh-huh unfortunately unfortunately
accident last week about what resistant
Patterson was calibrating one of the
core committers in the chamber uh-huh
witnesses say he appeared to you see
something okay
something was talking to him just get to
the pint
he backed right into the particle beam
that's not good it was not a pretty
sight no I don't think that oh that's
neither they drive minutes although I'm
not sure you can consider that living
but they say his eyes rolled back and
forth and he was trying to talk although
Kothari Brown losing that much brain
matter I'm sure was his reflex actions
okay due to this I have enacted new
safety protocols in the lab uh-huh we
have stocked one of the storage cabinets
with emergency medical supplies okay
code for the cabinet yeah seven five two
seven five two can you just stop in the
man that you with that Oh
what is this what is this are you alive
or dead hey alright where's the nade I'm
gonna try this [ __ ] out I can see stuff
Oh
don't breathe on me shooting me alright
I got have done this episode here but
anyway like everybody you enjoy it it's
gotta come real J and let's see an
exception where I buy my make sure mode
activate
[Music]